Are there specific indications or parameters that is blood that allows the discovery of cancer in an early stage and what are these parameters or indications.
And our indications are parameters different for each kind of cancer.
Okay, well.
That speaks to something I was just talking to my staff about today because I'm and see these Instagram posts and the space for posts.
Say, really nice little infographic that says one blood test can find, you know, 20 different cancers or 12 different cancers. I don't remember what it said.
And it was very nice looking infographic and I thought, was there something else on the market. So I've been on it and clicked on it.
And it was talking about tumor marker testing, which told me that that infographic and whoever is putting it out and I didn't go any deeper to find out who was publishing this or paying for the ads.
It was.
Very misleading to the point of.
It's just a lot of you can't diagnose cancer with a tumor marker test. So you, I have a blog post on two workers. I'm very big into using two markers as a way to help you have another not invasive indication of.
You know, tracking your cancer can be beneficial. If you're, if your cancer is showing positive to markers that you can use that to help track your cancer.
You never use one test alone. Nothing stands on itself. Nothing is a perfect gold standard.
But to say that you would, you would do a tumor marker test and if those were negative, if those were all in range that you don't have cancer.
Oh my gosh, that's like male practice. It truly is because a person, you know, how many people have staged for cancer and all their tumor markers are within range because a lot of cancers don't show positive to workers at all.
And, you know, some typically will like PSA isn't to work for prostate cancer. Almost everybody was prostate cancer is going to have elevated PSA.
But there's a, there's a large percentage of women with breast cancer that are not going to have elevated CA 19.
19 or CA 15 three or CA 125 or so they're not going to have elevated tumor markers and they could have staged for breast cancer.
So to say that do you do a blood test and do a tumor marker test and it's negative in that you don't have cancers.
It could be an early indicator. So getting it like I'm just curious. I don't feel well and my mom at cancer and my dad at cancer. So I want to know to run a tumor marker panel.
It can give you some indications but it's just one test and don't be, you know, don't go off of one test and think that you don't have cancer and likewise you can have elevated to markers and you don't have cancer.
I think I could elevate to markers. We can't believe what you see out there is a lot of misinformation.
And yet, you know, I feel like we take such a balanced approach and yet Google and YouTube hate us and just don't get it but well.